wir treffen Oleg und seine Drohnen
abwehreinheit irgendwo im Erdgeschoss
eines Kia war Hochhauses mehrmals in der
Woche machen Sie hier freiwillig Dienst
die sind Veteranen deren aktive
Militärzeit lange zurückliegt manches
sind längst in Rente andere haben noch
kleine Jobs wenn sie nicht gerade ihre
Stadt beschützen
unsere Hauptaufgabe ist das Warten bis
irgendwann drohnenalarm ausgelöst wird
wir sind hier ständig in Bereitschaft
sobald wir das Kommando bekommen rücken
wir aus und beziehen unsere
gefechtspositionen
die Warnung kommt oft so früh dass ihnen
genügend Zeit bleibt einen Hügel am
Stadtrand hoch zu kraxeln und das
schwere Maschinengewehr in Position zu
bringen die Waffe ist Baujahr 1944
bewährte Technik aus dem letzten
Weltkrieg offenbar noch gut genug für
den Hightech Krieg im 21 Jahrhundert
s wie uns zwischen der Grenze und Kiew
mit dieser geballten Feuerkraft gelingt
es uns immer wieder drohen runterzuholen
die Dinge haben flache Flüge die müssen
wir mehrmals treffen um ihre
Flugfähigkeit zu verändern damit sie
abstürzen bevor sie das Ziel treffen
können
zweimal hat olextrupp schon Drohnen 50
Meter über ihren Köpfen vom Himmel
geholt sie nehmen in Kauf dass das
Geschoss woanders einschlägt Hauptsache
ist trifft nicht sensible Infrastruktur
auf die hat es Russland seit Herbst
besonders abgesehen tief liegende
iranische Drohnen aber auch Raketen
haben immer wieder schwere Verwüstungen
angerichtet es gab Verletzte und Tote
das sind Handyaufnahmen von einer
anliegenden Rakete in der Nähe der Stadt
niepro der eigentliches Ziel hat sie
verfehlt wir wollen sehen was sie vor
der Stadt auf diesem Gnadenhof für Tiere
angerichtet hat
Gott sei Dank sind keine Menschen
umgekommen aber zehn Tiere haben wir
verloren diese kinsharrakete hat es beim
Absturz in mehrere Teile zerrissen die
Sprengladung ist da hinten
runtergekommen und nicht explodiert aber
der Treibstoff hat sich entzündet ein
Tiergehege und unsere ganzen
Futtervorräte gingen in Flammen auf und
auch viel Baumaterial
die verkohlten Pfosten hat stehen lassen
ihr Wohnhaus dahinter blieb ganz knapp
verschont seit jener Nacht hat sie noch
mehr Angst vor der Gefahr aus der Luft
bringt sich aber ab mit der Betreuung
der Tiere viele hat der Krieg hierhin
verschlagen ihre Besitzer haben sie auf
der Flucht in den Westen hier
abgeliefert können den dashcar kam
direkt von der Front
die Jungs von der 93 Brigade haben sie
gefunden sie lief ihnen einfach
hinterher und einmal als Feuer in ihrem
Unterstand ausbrach und die Munition
explodierte hat die Hündin die Soldaten
geweckt und gerettet sie kam als letzte
raus und war schwer verletzt sie hat
Narben auf der Nase und ein Ohr fehlt
ihr auch
diese kleine Ziegenherde musste sie
aufnehmen weil der Besitzer zum Militär
eingezogen wurde und niemand mehr da war
der sich um sie kümmern konnte
noch auf dem Lastwagen
weil sie nicht wussten
was wir brauchten Milch und Heu das
hatten wir damals noch gar nicht
jetzt beginnt der nächste kriegsfrühling
und neue Tierbabys werden geboren und
immer noch macht es jetzt gehen hier
Angst wenn in der nahegelegenen Stadt
nie pro Luftalarm ausgelöst wird aber
selbst ins sichere Ausland zu fliehen
ist für sie keine Option
wenn hier alle weglaufen für wen sollten
dann unsere Jungs kämpfen wir denken
dass unsere Front hier ist und wir
müssen mutig sein und unsere Jungs
inspirieren wenn die mal Fronturlaub
haben kommen sie hierher und verbringen
einen Tag bei uns das freut mich
jetzt gehen ihr hat Wirtschaft studiert
und betreibt mit ihrem Mann eigentlich
ein Autohaus jetzt steckt sie ihr
Erspartes in den Hof und auch in ihr
Therapieprojekt
sie will kinderspielerisch vom Grauen
des Krieges ablenken auch durch das
Herumtollen mit den Tieren
diese großen Pferde sollen Soldaten
unterstützen erlittene Traumata zu
überwinden
das funktioniert ganz gut ob Sie das
glauben oder nicht aber wenn Menschen im
Rollstuhl kommen spüren die Pferde das
sie kommen näher und berühren die
Kranken ganz sanft an den Beinen oder
der Brust
wir haben erlebt wie selbst ganz harte
Soldaten plötzlich geweint haben ohne
ein Wort zu sagen sie waren einfach
glücklich dass die Pferde sich so
verhalten haben
diese Pferdetherapie ist ein erstes
Angebot für Soldaten die aus dem Krieg
kommen ein Ende der Kämpfe ist noch
nicht abzusehen auch Oleg und seine
drohnenjäger werden in ihrer Stellung
noch oft eigene Ängste überwinden müssen
wenn sie ihre Stadt verteidigen
das ist unsere Aufgabe wir sind voller
Adrenalin wir vergessen alles andere um
uns herum erst hinterher denken wir
daran dass die Drohne ja auch über
unseren Köpfen explodieren kann dass sie
uns auch selbst treffen könnte du sagst
dir immer nur du musst sie runter holen
die Jungs an der Front haben es ja viel
schwieriger
an der Front haben sie oft nicht mal so
einen alten Holzofen der die Kälte
vertreibt in die Ukraine ihr Land
verteidigen ganz gleich ob im
Schützengraben oder am Stadtrand von
Kiew